thanks for the intro and uh thanks for
the organizers for inviting me they
invited me to give a purely classical
talk I mean one color if that is that it
proves that I'm old enough to give a
purely classical talk but partly because
I don't actually know quantum algorithms
so well bear with me hopefully you'll
find some of it useful so here's a
starting point if you asked anybody in
1919 theory maybe even me I'm not sure
which of the following methods would
scale up and get applied to large
problems in 2020 here are the candidates
that you might put them up put up
singular value decomposition linear
algebra a network flow shortest path
graph algorithms sophisticated data
structures that you've all probably seen
an optimization the title gives away the
answer to this question though but also
your dance talk already mentioned linear
algebra as one of those things that
potentially quantum could speed up very
well indeed that's partly the reason
that this talk is about these things so
the answer might have I would guess the
answer would have been two and three
they're a little more discreet a little
more current at that point but perhaps
the answer as we realize now is perhaps
more one and four this is arguable but
this this seems to be the picture so
that's a motivation to study a linear
algebra
there's crucial help here of course from
centuries of continuous mathematics that
plays a big role linear algebra is
beautifully understood and in fact we'll
see some problems to do with tensors at
the end not nearly as well understood or
theoretically developed as matrices and
linear algebra but also some part of it
is owed to these randomized algorithms
that I'm going to talk about in in this
slide and which is already mentioned by
ordinal the first talk okay so SVD
singular value decomposition was
mentioned and some applications here
which are different perhaps from the
applications that you saw earlier in
machine
topic modeling clustering is an
application learning mixture of
gaussians for which which is a standard
statistical model for which there's a
nice algorithm of Impala among which
projects things to their 3d subspace and
then learns which is a standard
technique in a lot of algorithms
non-negative matrix factorization is an
important area in machine learning where
you are given an input matrix you have
to factor it into two matrices with
non-negative entries which are lower
rank approximately or accurately both
are interesting and SVD is useful for
that SVD cannot be used directly because
it gives negative entries but this here
you want non negative well see this
negative and non negative playing a role
a little bit later this is simple for a
general audience for you it's simple who
tosses coins the algorithm tosses coins
that's randomized algorithms but average
case would have been a probabilistic
analysis where the data closest coins
here mostly the algorithm will toss
coins right today don't toss coins know
why randomized algorithms is again a
simple interval but there are two points
perhaps one of them is missed sometimes
first of all saving time and cube time
is expensive for matrix algorithms for
login but also space because in the
traditional algorithm setup we assume
that the data the matrix of the graph is
given an in ran and in random in unit
time you can access one edge or one
entry of the matrix not so when data
resides outside because it's too big
right time and space of odd
consideration a very simple form of
randomized algorithm which we will talk
about here is it just computes on a
sample of rows or columns of the matrix
and but we insist that we get proven
error guarantees right theorems let's
say not just heuristics but something
else perhaps a little more subtle when
you first encounter this it's just
sampling on the fly we shouldn't be
spending too much time on sampling
drawing a sample for instance important
sampling sometimes you can spend too
much time so you want to be able to
sample quickly on the fly now later in
the end maybe we'll deal with this thing
I may not get to it the input matrix may
be distributed among service
randomization will also help reduce the
commune
education because it's an extra worry
that we can think about there are two
scenarios again quite familiar but the
method is the same the first scenario
like the lab or more generally in
theoretical computer science one assumes
the matrix of the graph exists somewhere
and we are drawing samples from it but
conceptually different is something like
the Chaminda systems which you're all
familiar with where you don't have the
whole matrix anywhere you only have some
entries right but then you can pretend
that the matrix was got by sampling from
a whole matrix for that you have to know
something about the sampling
probabilities which were implicitly used
in drawing these samples right to prove
things okay the first part you have a
probability under your control the
second part you don't but I really will
think of both is the same and here
mostly we'll think of one we'll think of
the probability distributions being
under our control so they're setting
large matrix and an M large I want to
pick s is a size as a sample S stands
for sample in iid trials in each trial
we pick a column with some probabilities
and scale it
I don't compute only with the sample
then scaled matrix with s columns so
lots of columns in some matrix with as
columns your sample just doesn't deal
with it okay so the problems that we
will talk about maybe I won't get to all
of them but maybe you will matrix
multiplication is just multiplying two
matrices in particularly even a a
transpose is interesting or generally
more two different matrices singular
value decomposition low-rank
approximation matrix sketches where you
can represent a matrix in smaller amount
of space this is again Yunus talked
about the COR decomposition I'll get to
that graphs falsification is a reason
not varies a ten-year old result of
Spielman and Srivatsa which is beautiful
which actually depends on length great
sampling as we'll see linear regression
finally I want to talk about tensors
where perhaps there are open questions
that people haven't tried to use quantum
things to and
maybe that's possible maybe I mean this
is again going out on a limb without
knowing a lot about it
two things no free lunch you're sampling
so you can't get exact answers you're
gonna make errors right what will prove
very guarantees okay good
so not I don't want to impose too much
foundation on you but a little bit for
business norm squared is the sum of
squares of all the entries of the matrix
and spectral norm is the maximum overall
unit length vectors of a X so how much a
dilates a vector in in inverse direction
maximum direction a is always n by n s
is always the number of samples that
much for notation no more okay so now
I'm going to state for you some results
and tell you what what sampling is going
to go on and you can think about how
quantum leap some of this this has been
improved quantumly in fact the next top
way even might be it's some of our
results and other results that might be
on that we'll see ok so we seek an
approximation of rank K to a matrix a
the best approximation you can find by
classical linear algebra is by finding
what's called a singular value
decomposition which is like spectral
decomposition except the matrix of an f
is symmetric and there's an error I'm
going to allow an error because I don't
want to spend time to do the exact thing
so the error I'm going to allow is some
small constant epsilon times the
Frobenius norm and this theorem simply
says with number of samples which
doesn't depend on the size of the matrix
that's very important the number of
samples S is independent of the size of
the matrix it depends on this epsilon it
depends on that K only those the matrix
could in fact the infinite we'll see
examples of that that's also actually
interesting in practice provided the
sampling is done with probability is
proportional to the squared length of
the columns so you take the columns
these are real matrices I'm talking
about take the column sum of squares the
entries probability of picking that
column should be proportional to that
all links sorry
just a length squared of the column
Euclidean length squared whole column
yes sample the whole column so yeah I
pick whole subsets of columns here you
could also do other things but yeah so
it's only interesting it's not going to
always give you a good result see if I
tell you that I have an M by n matrix I
draw number of samples in the pendulum
and then I can do everything you
shouldn't believe me obviously right
because there's MN pieces of information
there so it's going to get an error and
it's interesting in in the case in some
important cases like PCA which is called
length width sampling this was in a
paper 98 there have been many
improvements
I put dot dot dots here to indicate
there's a lot of stuff that I'm not
mentioning and here are some of the
people who improve things there's an
alternative scheme maybe that's a
question there was a question there you
could draw instead a drum sample of
entries and set other entries to 0 okay
so you could specify the matrix but keep
the dimensions I won't talk much about
it this is some work of a clip this and
make sherry and some follow-up work has
happened on that as well but I will just
draw whole columns quite length scale
why these probabilities it turns out
they're very nice probabilities for a
very simple reason so suppose I want to
compute a a transpose you can write it
as a sum of outer products of columns of
a times the rows of a it's easy to see
and we're going to estimate this sum
which is sum over N Things by drawing a
sample so iid tiles now I'm going to do
I add a trans but not the uniform
probability so I'm going to pick column
J with probability PJ and I ask myself
what are the best PJs uniform sampling
is no good because a matrix could have
one important column and zero everywhere
else and if I draw samples I'd always
get zeros right and you can convince
yourself if I only see zeros the only
thing I can say about the matrix this is
all zeros just not going to be able to
approximation so I have to do something
I've got to weight the heavy columns
more and I'm going to rate it by length
squared first of all to make the
estimator unbiased it's good to divide
by the probability so the expectation is
right to stand
but the more important thing is some
calculus which I won't do here but
little calculus shows you that length
squared probabilities minimize the
variance so there's a good reason to use
length squared it's just be one that
minimizes the very simple ghettoes okay
so that's why we use length squared so
then you can prove something like this
where the error goes down as the number
of samples goes up to infinity this is
for a a transpose that length squared
minimizes the variance in that paper we
could also do matrix multiplication
using that in order star and squid star
involves factors depending on s okay so
matrix multiplication you can of course
do better than n cubed but N squared is
not known but this can do approximately
in its data handling in fast efficient
madness so this is another question that
comes up massive data too large to be
stored in ran right that's ice talked
about in the beginning a simplified
model is you measure RAM times phase a
number of passes so I cannot randomly
access an entry of the matrix but I can
access the matrix randomly access one
entry if I want by making an entire pass
it's very costly to access the matrix
you have to make a pass sequentially
right so you can count the number of
passes all these algorithms are two pass
algorithms you can make them one pass if
there is structure you can compute the
length squid in one pass and pass two
you can draw a sample so you and there
are ways of doing this with streaming
and less number of passes by now again I
won't mention those but so you can also
do the following I picked as columns
having done that I could pick a subset
of s rows out of those and I could only
work on an s bias matrix constant size
matrix but the proof that that gives you
error guarantee is much more complicated
but it's true that so you can call this
a constant time algorithm but the
running time does not depend after your
sample does not depend on the size of
the matrix
columns and so I got a tall skinny
matrix and out of that I sampled some
rows on length squared no III don't know
way of doing it simultaneously for which
I have a proof that there is generally
the problem is near singularity that
sketch of a matrix okay this is the cui
decomposition I'm going to talk about so
can I get a sample of rows of a matrix
tell you the story about the matrix the
old matrix now the unsampled rules are
on sample you don't know anything about
a sample of rules in a sample of columns
the answer is yes so the result is going
to be that for any matrix at all not for
a random matrix for any matrix just a
sample of rows and a sample of columns
tells you an approximation to the matrix
that's what we'll see but perhaps I'll
skip that
so length squared sampling rows and
columns now so you have a matrix I draw
s columns length squared sampling right
iid trials s iid trials one column each
time I draw some number of rows it turns
out to be not the same as root s for a
reason but again we won't go into but
I'll state the result in self-contained
fashion yes so yeah it is
so the error on the right hand side is
always proportional the Frobenius norm
it would be awfully nice to make it
spectral norm but it is not possible
matrix you can't approximate every
matrix with error that's epsilon times
just
although there are results about
approximating with spectrometer I'll get
to them give you the complexity which is
sort of like pipes that's right running
time is linear only yeah in one of the
things unless you go to constant size
unless you go to the more complicated
thing of sampling columns and out of
that sampling rows which I didn't touch
on because they are not practical but
it's you know
so so you you take rose from the whole
matrix now not just from the columns you
picked from the whole matrix so I should
give you a picture here I think I have a
pig here this so here are some columns
of the matrix here are some rules of the
matrix and the assertion is every matrix
can be well approximated by a product
like this where I give you the columns
and rows and use computed from C and R
so given just see in our columns and
rows there's a matrix you you can put in
the middle of the right dimensions which
you can compute so that the spectral
norm error between a and C or C are
approximate say is you should just check
it's a correct dimensions at least C
times ER it is goes down to 0 as a
number of samples increases there is
another bound also for the Frobenius
norm here but the right-hand side is
always Frobenius norm so far
and again the dot-dot-dot is really
quite a lot of stuff in between and with
citizen Woodruff have given off to most
times it it is defined yes it it
involves a pseudo inverse of C and some
other things here and I don't remember
now where but yes it is well-defined and
it's it's it's efficiently computable
from C n R so if you know your if you
remember yes we D this would have been
the singular values diagonal matrix
right spectral decomposition have been
eigen values but it's not diagonally
anymore here I mean the proof takes a
bit of doing I mean is good for yeah the
quality in practice you mean maybe oh
I'll put down some applications yeah
yeah I'll put down some applications
yeah so I mean is this not completely
useless but it's buddy-buddy but it is
nobody I have a good question
no but the question is good because
they're errors are a lot I mean because
you so traditionally sweetie given data
matrix finds the best rank a to issues
computation time this was referred to so
some of the application one of the
applications is to the Health Sciences
right there you have a gene patient
matrix if you did SVD you can go back
and tell the biologists the principal
component is 17 times the first patient
minus 12 times the 31st patient and so
on so forth right now biologists don't
like making multiple copies of a patient
right and they certainly don't like
subtracting patients because hey this is
a bad thing to do but anyway
interpolating approximation here what
see you are does it tells you here or
some page you can tell the values here
are some patients and here are some
genes that with these you can represent
the whole thing actual patient's and
actual means right this was worked by
Nunez Mahoney this application the
applications our database was by
philosophers and
there are a bunch of other application
to see you are but I I didn't put them
all up but here's a couple of
representative was
so let me see let me go over fast some
of this till I come to a slide where I
wake you up and then you can pay
attention if you so a transpose is
interesting because the
variance-covariance matrix if you have a
probability density on Rd the variance
covalence make this is the expected
value of x IX j4x picked according to P
right now you can think of a matrix a
which is d by infinity in d dimensions
where each point is a column each point
is a column and it weighted by the
probabilities in some way the variance
along Direction V is just this which is
V transpose a squared so it's how much a
magnifies V right sample complexity how
many iid samples do you need to estimate
a a transpose but I'll tell you what
estimate means you want the relative
error we want to sample some columns a
finite sum subsample of columns B of a
so that in every direction
the magnification B gives the
magnification a give all close with in
relative Epsilon it's very important
that it's relative error in fact this is
actually directly applied for graphs
falsification as we'll see in a minute
but you need relative error that's non
trivial so along the low eigen values
you don't have much error allowed so
this question came up in a completely
different context volume competition
actually there's going to be a talk on
quantum computing and volume computation
later in the day I see okay so the the
thing we proved is all Frobenius norm on
the right hand side somebody asked me a
question and now there is actually a
better result due to rules inversion and
using some nice function analysis they
prove the following what seems to be a
technical improvement one of the fobian
aslam terms has been replaced by a
spectral law but it's actually a much
more fundamental improvement it's not
just technical it's crucial for
applications like graphs publications
now there are simple proof so this
without going into the function analysis
technique by using matrix Chernov
inequality
these have tincture of inequalities for
matrices kudos inversion and theorem
implies the number of samples order
start D where D the dimension is enough
for law concave sampling and this is an
important question
Spearman siree that's why I use this to
do what's called spectrums falsifies let
me define that you have a graphite n
nodes an images and you have a node edge
incidence matrix question that was asked
is can I have a much sparser sub graph
which has the same behavior on all the
cuts and or same behavior in a minute
I'll mention that this was a question
and answer asked and answered by Benzer
and Karger to some extent a stronger
condition was Spearman rivets words
which says instead of just cut I want
every vector to be magnified the same
amount roughly by the adjacency matrix
also know the edge instance matrix of a
and the sub graph so sub graph reflects
the magnification of AG well on in every
direction same question arises this and
torrelson rush in and gives you this
but if I can make a of G and isometry
isometry means it magnifies all vectors
all vectors the same amount if I can
make it an isometry then I can get
better results and so maybe it's time to
wake up in a way so let me tell you this
slide and next it's good to be awake but
so I'm gonna call this precondition legs
quite sampling this is also something
that the next stop might refer to
because her work sort of involves this
as well so you have a matrix a I want to
make it an isometry I wanted to magnify
every vector the same amount so I do
that by hitting it with the inverse
right it becomes identity we don't have
an inverse sees and animal not equal so
you can hit with the pseudo inverse and
then we can sample columns at a two
length squared probabilities but from
the isometry from the precondition we
call it precondition because it's as if
W is a pre-conditioner for a it's a
standard numerical analysis term so I
take the precondition matrix and take
length squared sampling on that so
squared lengths of the columns of the
precondition matrix right and we repeat
this as times the Rudolf's inversion and
result gives you a relative error about
that it could be shown that that gives
you a little bit about so what seemed
like a technical improvement was
actually quite important this is true
for any matrix
Speedman's favors if I did the following
for adjacency matrix of graphs they
showed that the sampling can be done in
linear time so I want to sample the
probabilities proportional to the length
squared or W times a I have to compute W
perhaps and I have to hit it with a and
then sample so all of this can be done
in quasi linear times what they show
well that's only for laplacian snow it's
possible father drafts this can be done
I don't know perhaps it can even be done
more efficiently quantumly then why with
the monistic me by classical means I
don't know but that's that's some
question to us can you finding the
inverse one thing it's a standard
question but here all you need is
sampling the probability is proportional
to the precondition matrix maybe that
can be done
so this relates to leverage cause let me
skip this slide and do the last
paragraph and then the picture so I here
want to draw a sample of columns of a
with probabilities not proportional to
squared length but the square is the
volume of the simplex planned by them
this turns out to be quite important
both in algorithms and and probability
theory determinative processes are
important that's illustrated by a
picture right so here's a picture of why
determinants determinantal sampling is
important so if you do a search for
Jaguar there are at least two meanings
or more but if I plot the car vectors
they might all be close to each other if
I plot the animal vector they might all
be close to each other if I just did
length squared sampling and pick ten
columns out of it maybe the car is so
much more prevalent that I will get nine
out of ten or all ten out of ten cars
okay that's not representative instead I
might want to know all meanings and
sample from them so what volume sampling
says is pick a pair of columns at a time
with probability proportional to the
square of the area of the triangle they
span so that's the same as the
determinant okay so I take if I if I
take this this vector and this one car
one animal they're almost orthogonal so
they span a larger area triangle then if
I pick these two right the base times
height the height is very small if I
take these so volume sampling avoids
this problem by taking the volume into
consideration so one question for you is
there a quantum efficiency you can gain
for volume sampling so more generally I
want to pick
I'm giving I give you a set of vectors
and I want to pick a subset of K of them
with probability proportional to the
volume of the simplex they span or the
determinant of that matrix squared can
you get an advantage over just ordinary
sampling
bhaiyya numerating all of them so it is
even a very simple much simpler question
which must be trivial for most of you
perhaps that's why I hesitated to put
that on slides but here I have X I 1
through n belonging to minus 1 and plus
1 I want to pick a subset T of n with
probability of picking T proportional to
the sum of X I over T squared now this
is not exactly a special case of that
but this seems too much simpler version
can you get a quantum advantage here
over two to the N times poly I mean so
you can beat you want to beat two to the
N times poly which you can easily do
ideally you want to beat it by a lock so
you want to get a poly time maybe this
is familiar I mean I I it's possible
that some of you have looked at and
solve this question so determines the
processes is the general case of this
now I think I have two minutes because
you know maybe this is skeptical but I
think I'll okay to do a quick minute
so tensor is another area which perhaps
there are quantum advantages to be had
so tensor means you know three or more
dimensional so we want to maximize one
standard problem with tensors akin to
singular vectors or singular values
eigen values and so on and so forth if
you want to maximize the cubic form over
unit length like this so I have a ijk
three tensor and I want to maximize this
thing right can you do something about
that well turns out you can here's the
theorem for any fixed epsilon can find
in poly time or Y satisfying this best
possible off by epsilon times the
Frobenius norm of a which is sum of
squares square root same definition this
is sum of square square and this is an
algorithm again I won't be able to
describe the algorithm except to say
that does involve in the bowels links
quite sampling
I don't know here's the question can you
do perhaps this for tensors can you get
an advantage over
either the traditional desktop or this
algorithm the better results are known
for tensors if you have structure well I
think I think I won't go over the rest
there are enough slides I I'm always
afraid of running out of light so it's
better that's all I'll swap here
[Applause]
random predictions randomized
predictions for instead of settling
whole roads and college so do Janson
linen and struts kind of projection and
then okay so the difficulty is that the
singular vector singular values a single
vector space right is one space and
everywhere else it may be for instance
maybe rank a like or rank one video
random projection you lose that
potentially right everything gets
contracted by the same amount so you're
talking about count sketching the more
recent things or you're talking about
just random so there are now methods
which are in the slides I didn't show
you where you can use certain random
projections to do something but a naive
random projection is likely to lose
likely to miss the singular vector space
which is the important space but it is
one space hiding out of it's a needle in
a haystack so the nice haystack as well
as a needle will be contracted the same
amount by random position you can miss
it
thank you
[Applause]